Kyle Keller stephen f austin head coach
joins us now how much sleep have you had
coach he wrote we we got out of there
late last night and and you know we had
a lot of different things to do and then
we flew into Tyler Texas I'm not sure if
you know where that is that's about we
had some fans that greeted us there at
the airport and then it's been hour and
a half from Nacogdoches and I've been
rolling ever since I got home so I'm
gonna go recruiting here in a little bit
so I haven't had a chance to get any
sleep ya know it's a good time to real
good time to go recruiting after that
win against Duke okay if I said to you
24 hours ago hey you're gonna beat Duke
in overtime what would you say honestly
what would you said if it's not on the
radio it's just privately and I'm
talking to you
what do I have to give up to make that
happen - kids you know that you know
there obviously there's a far fetched
yield for everybody but you know we as a
coach and players you're going to expect
him to win but the general public says
they got no shot right then I mean come
on you know there's realistically then
lost in how many years at home - in a
non-conference game and you know
somebody's telling me there's a loss
turn on power five seems like 83 so
that's why you know coach says coaches
so he's the gold standard I mean you
don't let his team slip and but we
caught him at the right time
what was that pregame speech length last
night it was just you know be yourself
you know and just be who we are and and
you know I told him I said hey you know
cuz I really gave my best spiel a time
the night before but but it was just a
be ourselves just go out there because
in our league we're I'm not gonna say
we're Duke but in our league everybody
gives us our best shot and so I said for
the first time we've really this year
there's no pressure on you guys all the
pressures on them just go out there and
have fun play together play connective
and just enjoy the moment try not to
look up at all the people they're gonna
be staring at you
things that you just have fun with each
other and because at home all the
pressure and where we go around our
league all the pressures on us one a few
times in the year where we go out there
and just play pressure for you and I
think that's a great point because you
know as you're saying look we're not
Duke on a national stage but in our
conference in our league we are Duke
we're the team that everybody gears up
for so your players know what that
feeling is where you have to where we
judge you on how much you won by not
that you won but it's like oh you only
won by seven you know
Coach K has had that for the last thirty
years where we're going on 40 years oh
yes what happened you struggle the only
one by 19 yeah at night yeah percent I
put up actually I gave our guys blind
draw stats are stats versus their stats
and one of the things I did the night
before the game and they're remarkably
pretty similar and before the game I
said you tell me whose dancer whose and
you know I asked the guys that they're
no different than us you know I didn't
you know I mean am i get thankfully my
guys they don't go to Duke so they ain't
as smart as their guy you know I
couldn't figure that out but so you know
I mean it's you know I said tell me
who's who
I said guys we're doing it we're gonna
win I said we do what they do
we played pressure defense we play fast
we rebound the heck out of it and I said
we're gonna find out who can do it
better tomorrow night and we're gonna
will ourselves to do it better and you
know I didn't want to tell them they've
got lottery picks here and first-round
draft picks and McDonald's all-americans
and all that kind of stuff I mean just
just worked out any thought to you know
calling a timeout
you know when Ben gets that layup like
would is he instructed he gets the steal
but is he instructed to just go and play
or was there any thought of a timeout
dan I'm looking down at it guys 112
hundred games am I gonna out coach him
are you serious I didn't want him to
have a clipboard I mean okay you know
that's that was not even a motive
thought you know it it'd be honest with
you
I talked to the guys before the game is
crazy and the guys brought it up after
the game but I thought their pressure
defense would really affect us and I
told them if they got stuck with the
ball with four or five seconds I said
just drive that thing as hard as you can
to the rim versus casting up a 3-point
shot because of the pressure defense I
said try to draw a foul try to draw
something you have plenty of time I said
we go in the end in five seconds you
know a couple of times a week and they
bein told me after the game was always
said coach that's all I thought about
when I got that ball as I go Indian lay
it up I got plenty of time and that's
the first time he's ever listened to me
what was the postgame celebration like
in the locker room you know it's for us
at this level it was is what we live for
I mean it's euphoric it's you know a lot
of Gatorade a lot of water unfortunate I
got it we ran out of water so by the
time I got in there was a lot of ice and
I found out watching it over and over
again my wife continues show me I have a
lot less hair than what I thought I had
on the top of my head when it's wet it
was a lot of fun it was it was that's
what we live for at this level you know
I spent 18 years at Oklahoma State at
Kansas in a a.m. and you don't get those
locker room celebrations unless you
advance deep in it in the tournament or
win a conference championship and that
you're not supposed to do you really
don't get them a conference championship
just going to Final Four or something
like that so here you live for you know
that's what makes this level great it's
fun to see Congrats coach and thanks
good lucky man you and I we met once
before you won't remember it but you
made a great impression on me how kind
of man you were when you're working at
another network ESPN you you came and
did Sunday night conversation with mr. I
bow and I was a ho my goodness this and
you were so kind you kind of hung out
with me and a couple other guys at
Eskimo Joe's and I was working for
Leonard Hamilton at the time and you
were so kind and so to every person that
you met
and what a great person you are in this
profession what you've done for sports
but I appreciate the opportunity to
visit with you you know 30 years later
or whatever and it's a 29 years later
whatever but I appreciate it that's
quite impression upon me and I
appreciate you doing some on mister I
bow yeah Hank I bow was this basketball
legend he was the coach of the u.s.
Olympic team that lost to the Russians
and I never I just didn't want him to be
thought of as the coach who lost to the
Russians lost the gold medal game and he
was you know this unbelievable figure
and I went out and did a Sunday
conversation with him I think we played
basketball and I have a Gallagher arena
we had a pickup and also when we went to
Eskimo Joe's which was the bar in town I
think I went with Mike Gunter was Mike
Gundy there and coach Pat Jones does
that so that's right and I remember we
were doing shots of 151 rum and the bar
caught on fire and nobody was concerned
that the bar caught on fire that day
that was my nose my memory there coach
they're pretty good pretty good I miss
Oklahoma you know it you know eventually
in the cold or something's gonna you
know the winds gonna blow in the other
direction or you know that's how it's
supposed to be and there was a young
assistant coach by name of Bill Self and
her staff at that time who kind of made
some of them yeah he seems to you've
gone through an awful lot so Kyle you
know this story with Oklahoma State the
plane crash and you know you're an
assistant for a long long time and you
get this opportunity so you know
congrats to you because this is a this
is a business of persevering and being
told no probably but you know it's a big
win and I know you got to the tournament
I think you played Texas Tech last year
right yeah it's been fun a lot of fun
with the winningest program in the state
we've had a lot of fun or last decade so
all right if you wake up you might have
to be reminded that you beat Duke last
night okay so when you wake up just have
your wife say yes you did beat Duke last
night safe travels
or Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]